what went on behind this door during
covered lockdowns now in sharp focus and
finally becoming clearer after weeks of
going round in circles about what
happened in the downing street garden in
the cabinet room in the corridors of
power we now know that those who set the
rules broke them the pm and his
chancellor fined for lockdown breaches
as was the prime minister's wife carrie
johnson today i've received a
fixed penalty notice from the
metropolitan police relating to an event
in downing street on the 19th of june
2020 and let me say immediately that
i've paid the fine and i once again
offer a full
apology i have to say in all frankness
at that time
it did not occur to me uh that this
might have been a breach of the rules
but of course the police have found
otherwise and i
fully respect the outcome of their
investigation
i understand the anger that many will
feel that i myself fell short when it
came to observing the very rules which
the government i lead had introduced to
protect
the public
and i accept in all sincerity that
people had the right to expect better
that apology and fine for one gathering
that took place inside number 10 in june
2020 on the pm's birthday but there are
plenty more which for weeks were
dismissed or denied no laws no rules
broken i can tell you that the
guidelines were followed at all times
the guidance was followed and the rules
were followed at all times have you lied
to the public and parliament
no bet if sue grey uncovers a different
version of events and emerges you did
mislead parliament will you resign
we'll have to see what she says do you
believe you may have broken the rules
no
despite those denials the police have
fined the prime minister and his
chancellor for rule breaking and that
raises questions about their political
futures the code of conduct for all
government ministers is clear those who
knowingly mislead parliament are
expected to resign the guilty men of the
prime minister and the chancellor
they've dishonored all of that sacrifice
they've dishonored their office
this is the first time in the history of
our country that a prime minister's been
found to be in breach of the law
and then he lied repeatedly to the
public about it
britain deserves better
they have to go
but for his own mps even those who have
called for him to go now is not the time
i previously said his position it was
not tenable at the time i said that it
was at the turn of the year when these
allegations became very clear there was
photographic evidence and but things
have moved on since then it doesn't take
away the anger
the fury the people still have and
rightly and i share that but i'm also
looking at the situation in ukraine
it's worth pausing just a moment to take
this all in a sitting prime minister
fined by the police for breaking rules
he himself set boris johnson repeatedly
told parliament the public his own party
that all guidelines had been followed at
number 10 during those coveted lockdowns
we now know that simply is not
true
and despite it being an unparalleled
situation it could get worse for him
still he's still under investigation for
other alleged lockdown breaches and more
fines could be on the way
and even though he's in such political
hot water this is a prime minister who
for now appears to defy political
gravity with his mps seeming unwilling
to move against him at a time of war but
the big question is still what do the
voters make of it
for many people here in boris johnson's
uxbridge constituency these fines spell
the end of the line for our leaders they
should be sacked
end off i think you should resign yeah
of course
yeah it's not a good luck to have a liar
as a as a country's leader i think he's
had a lot to deal with
so you know he's got bigger priorities
to deal with such as uh ukraine he
probably should resign a fine's not
enough it's hypocritical it's not
something you want in the leader
the pm tonight hunkering down in his
other official home checkers but he
can't escape the pressure of partygate
on his premiership or the voters verdict
when the local elections come around in
may beth rigby sky news westminster